also wie es in dieser staffel und in den
nächsten weiter geht wissen wir ja
nämlich ohne dieter bohlen dass er nicht
mehr dabei ist auch im nächsten jahr das
wurde ja schon vor zwei wochen
bekanntgegeben damals hiess es aber noch
dass er beim finale definitiv dabei sein
wird und ich muss sagen ich habe damals
schon so gedacht okay wie soll das
funktionieren weil so ein mann der so
ein ego hat und so rausgekickt in
anführungsstrichen ja wurde wie er wie
es mit ihm gemacht wurde weil wir wissen
alles war nicht freiwillig dass er
gegangen ist
da fragt man sich dann in dem moment
einfach so wie kann er denn die gute
miene zum bösen spiel machen und sich
dahin setzen und einfach diese live
shows durchziehen das hat man sich schon
gefragt aber der plan war immer dass mit
ihm zu machen
und laut unseren informationen war es
auch bis gestern der plan also man hat
die live shows mit ihm geplant mann
hatte wie wir sie auch haben einen
sendeplan und den dass man durch
gegangen und dabei eher ein teil von und
dann soll es laut unseren informationen
ein gespräch mit dieter boden gegeben
haben und dieses gespräch muss wohl so
eskaliert sein dass er daraufhin die
krankschreibung eingereicht hat und
damit das finale und das halbfinale was
jetzt diesen samstag stattfindet
abgesagt hat aber geäußert hat er sich
dazu jetzt noch nie wir haben ihn
angerufen er ist auch ans telefon
gegangen aber dieter möchte sich nicht
äußern
de facto hat ehrlicherweise einfach
irgendwann aufgelegt dazu gehört dann
hat er aufgelegt und dieter redet aber
nicht nur mit uns nicht sondern er redet
auch mittlerweile wie wir gehört haben
laut unseren informationen auch nicht
mehr mit rtl denn mittlerweile geht
jetzt wohl nur noch alles über anwälte
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren